okay thank you fo welcome to my top more
dimensions you may wonder what this
title is all about it's one of those
titles that you can choose and then the
night before he can decide what you're
going to talk about and that is exactly
what I want to do it may be still
floating I don't know what's the going
to be in this talk at the very end and i
hope to entertain you now for 30 minutes
before we go for the food processing all
right the talk is roughly structured
according to the dimensionality of the
data data come in all kinds of
dimensions you may be very well aware if
you have one dimensional data like sound
or time series and there are two
dimensional data like images three
dimensional data like volumes or movies
and then of course there are n
dimensional data that may not be
perceived as such but as soon as you
have a data set and you create all kinds
of features these features create n
dimensional feature space and you can
also apply all kinds of mathematical
routines as you will see in this
conference on these n dimensional
feature spaces all right the current
table of contents as of now is the
following I will start up with some
subtle differences between event series
and time series which is our format for
one dimensional data sets then I'll
apply those to do some forecasting since
we're here in Frankfurt the city of
money and we'll try to do some
forecasting regarding precious metals so
you can try to get your expenses again
back in sound processing I will try to
measure the speed here on the Autobahn
via Doppler effect I will do some give
some examples about resampling theory
and all the built-in resampling methods
that we have taken give the example of B
spot interpolation then I will do a very
simple fun example processing the images
of a fish tank then I'll do some image
processing so some 2d signal processing
by removing and adding image data by
doing image restoration and then
eventually go to 3d images that is
2d images plus time so looking at
animations I will try to do motion
magnification and last but not least
just as a kind of a final remark I will
again mention the future of all of this
which is eventually deep learning as you
have seen in previous talks today about
image identify all right let's just get
going utilize the time okay there is a
subtle difference between what's called
an event Siri and the time Siri in
Mathematica an event series basically
good for data that does not have
intrinsic interpolation so the typical
example for this are okay let's see if I
have connections to the Internet I hope
so our earthquakes well earthquakes are
fairly discrete events no it doesn't
seem to ring a bell so let me just quit
this and use the pre-loaded data
earthquakes are discrete events and so
it doesn't make any sense to take to
interpolate between two earthquakes I
mean either there's an earthquake
there's no earthquake so an earthquake
should be an event series unfortunately
earthquake currently come in into
mathematic as a time series which is it
strictly speaking in a book but I can
rectify that very quickly in Mathematica
by wrapping event series around
earthquakes and then i have actually
invent series object whoops in
Mathematica as you can see here and I
can visualize that and hear what you see
are now the earthquakes in the
metropolitan area of Tokyo from 1950
until the beginning of this year and you
can see there are irregular so these are
not regularly sample data they re
regular sample data and they are
discrete so what I can do for example
with this kind of data I can translate
those into energies these are the
magnitudes of the earthquake according
to the Richter scale so I get here now
event series for the for the energy I
can plot that again and that gives me a
much more dramatic picture of what's
actually going on how much energy is
released in this area in jail and jewel
by the way
and then just as one example of many
filters that we now have for time series
or vent series for regularly sampled or
irregularly sample data is now here a
mean filter that basically takes the
average over a certain time span that I
can specify here either in seconds or as
a quantity here for example I'll have a
radius for that mean filter of half a
year and it will just take the average
magnitude of the average energy of of
earthquakes within a year and then I can
plot those two and what it does
basically is it does not weigh that data
with the time of the event but just the
magnitude or the energy itself in that
respect it just just looks at this
discrete events without looking at the
time spent in between this is now for
event series and the subtle difference
I'd like to point out is now in contrast
to time series time series are in our
measurements in time we're in principle
you could talk about interpolation
basically if you have an observable that
is continuous then you typically would
have the time theory and well handful
yeah now I have a connection in case you
haven't been outside it's 19 degrees
outside here in Frankfurt this is a
temperature as a typical continuous
observable but the measurements you'll
do most likely will be discreet so we
have for that the object the time series
object and the times here is object
basically comes with its own
interpolation recipe first of all of you
of course you have discrete data and
there but underlying the idea is it's
continuous and as I set here down here
you have a resampling method built in
and in this case it says it has a linear
interpolation as a built-in model and
the neat thing now is that if you
process such a time series in
Mathematica it takes that under model
underlying model into account so if I
now take the mean filter on this it does
not take the average of time
measurements in a certain time interval
which may go terribly bad because they
are irregularly sampled in this case but
basically
constructs the underlying interpolating
function and then basically integrates
over a certain time area so it weighs
the data according to the time steps in
between and then I can do that
automatically here just by calling up
mean filter on the temperature
specifying I want to have a six day
every June window and these are now the
averaging temperatures in Frankfurt in
the month of May ok let's try to take or
bring well make something sensible out
of time series is one thing to talk
about the past it's a completely
different thing about talking about the
future especially when it comes to
financial objects and here I'd like to
quickly load into mathematica the value
of silver gold and platinum from the
date first of January 2013 until
yesterday the first of jun 2015 so I'll
just load them here one by one okay
lucky the network is working and then I
just convert those into a time series
that is regularly spaced so in case you
sample your data irregularly that
weekends are not included for example
this is the standard way to make sure
that you have a regularly sample to time
series to do all kinds of processes and
the process that we do is now the
following first of all we convert it
into time series with the corresponding
magnitudes taking out so it's not noted
in u.s. dollars or Euros anymore and we
multiply silver by effect of 100 to have
roughly the same number sighs and we
obtained here time series and now I take
that time series which I call metals and
plot it and this is the plot this is
basically the value of gold silver and
platinum over the last two years and you
can see the decline and now I'd like to
know what the future will hold so I do a
estimate a process and the process that
I try to estimate here is an armored
process or
we put the week stationary
autoregressive moving average process
that I try to fit onto the data whoops
no I didn't mean to sorry did not mean
to
okay I fit that on the data and I get
here this armor process now that tries
to reproduce the data and I use that
process to basically do a forecast into
the future for the next three month and
first year I can verify if that process
actually is a weekly stationary and if
it's invertible and if so i can try here
a forecast a forecast of three times 30
days and then i can plot this and as you
can see we do get a forecast which is
pride quite profound you can see that
there's supposed to be quite a gain in
silver price in the next few months to
come so if you trust me please best if
we fail i blame it on the machine okay
so this would be one dimensional data
processing but both pretty dry we are
working with data that you can't relate
to so i quickly change the subject and
now talk about speed and sound well we
are in germany and i know for example
that Conrad loves to take his car to
Germany to do some speeding on the
Autobahn and of course also in some
places you have a speed limit here and
you can use Mathematica to measure the
speed and you can do it very simply you
just have to put up your iPhone iPad
your computer or whatever record the
sound of the car driving by and just by
the sound of the car driving by you can
determine the speed in Mathematica and
that's what we're going to do now as a
kind of a signal processing signal
processing example so the sound sample
that I have here sounds like this what
you hear is it coming that was our con
right now but the sound that you hear is
basically the typical Doppler effect you
have the high pitch initially and then
it goes down to a lower pitch as your
first as the approach it's a high pitch
as you leave it's a lower pitch and what
we also have to know of course is a
sample rate of this sound sample which
is in this case 800 8192 hurts ok so
what we do first first we have to well
let just get the amplitudes of the sound
we have to get the frequencies and for
that I'll do here a continuous wavelet
transform
with a gobble wavelet and this gives me
kind of visual feedback of what the
sound that we just listened to looks
like it can hear basically vertically
you can see the spectrum the different
frequencies of the sound and the x-axis
is the time axis basically going from 0
to 5 seconds and you can see how the
frequencies being initially a little
higher drop as a car goes by and what we
need to know is now the difference in
frequency initially ended at the end and
even if we know the shape we can even
determine the distance by which the car
mr. missed us so I'll try to do all of
that first of all I don't have to have
that higher sampling rate so I just down
sample the whole thing by 32 effect of
32 and then I do something here that is
a little bit complicated I regularize
first the data by gorshin so I average
first the amplitudes before I subsample
so I basically do a proper subsampling
and then what I do here is the following
I basically have here the wavelet data
at one instant of time and I compared to
the wavelet data at the next instant of
time and I Pat this so I can do the
following I can do a correlation and I
do the correlation by shifting the
scales of the next are of the next
frequency or of the next wavelet
timestamp and just by moving it up and
down I can see where i can get the
highest correlation and when i get a
correlation I know how the frequency
change from one step to the next or how
the scale in the wavelet transform
changed and to exactly see how change
that do find Peaks because that's where
I get the highest correlation
coefficient and knowing the highest
correlation coefficient I know the shift
in scaled and I accumulate the scale and
by that I know the scale shift over time
which I determine here and then I
convert the scale of the wavelet
transform into frequencies and last but
not least i do plot this and this is the
shift in frequency or scale normalized
to the average frequency and you see
initially
you're about five percent higher in the
frequency or the pitch and when the car
is departing it's about five percent
lower and having this curve this
character's characteristic
characteristic curve I can now go ahead
and try to fit the formula that I have
for the Doppler effect which i'm not
going to derive here please just take my
word for it it's this formula for car
driving by by at a given distance d with
a velocity V and where t0 is the time
where the car basically is just next to
me so I do a nonlinear fit of this model
and once I can I have done that fit I
can call up here the parameter table and
I can read out one by one the data and
the data reads here that the car was
going 70 kilometers an hour so not that
fast really and if you also need of d
you can see that the car missed you by
about four point seven meters and all of
that taking out just out of a audio
recording so an example for signal
processing in 1d ok let's slowly climb
up the dimensionality leather and before
I do so I want to have kind of an
intermediate topic and that is the
resampling because we have put a lot of
effort into resampling theory in
Mathematica and just to motivate that I
quickly repeat some very simple
resampling well for example linear
resampling you probably know just linear
interpolation is pretty easy and if you
have regular grid or regular sampling
it's nothing else but basically taking a
so-called first order b-spline or this
kind of pyramid or unit triangle and
always place it everywhere where you see
a sample with a corresponding amplitude
and if you do that you interpolate here
for example Justice bike data or you
interpolate any kind of data but just
adding up these pyramids under the data
itself and adding it up well if you do
hbu a cubic b spline interpolation you
don't have this pyramid anymore this
triangular shape colonel but you have a
much more smoother one that is smooth
even up to second derivative order and
thereby you get a much nicer
interpolation but actually it's not an
interplay
if you look closely it's an X its lip
approximation so you don't go through
your data samples anymore but you cut
corners by doing this and on top of it
as you can see here it's more like a
blur than an interpolation so it's not
that great and that's why many people
really think B spline interpolation is
not a great thing to do but it is
actually not quite true because there's
a previous step you have to add to B
spline interpolation and that is
basically undo the blurring and I'm
doing the blurring you can do with the
built-in z-transform in Mathematica very
nicely and please bear with me if you
don't know now the mathematics that i'm
applying here i'll be back on track in
just a minute but i don't have time now
to explain as he transforms in all these
things the idea is as follows the better
kernel or the kernel that i apply here
has this discrete a shape its 162 third
16 if you want to discrete grit and i
want to undo that Colonel blurring or
that Colonel effect if I convolve and so
what I do here is I create a Z transform
and now for the z-transform I just try
to find the inverse and then go back to
the corresponding or a lot of that in
verse I will construct an operation that
basically will then undo the blurring so
I have here a transfer function of this
but I take the rest broke so that's the
transfer function of the inverse
operations of the unblurred operation
and I could even factorize that so I
basically convert that as two operations
and I can also simplify that here as a
system model series connect so I can
basically have a series of these two
operations one after another applied and
it will do the inverse or the D blurring
and I can do that as a recurrence filter
which works nicely if you go this way I
can't do it also is a recurrence filter
for the second term but that second term
if you look closely isn't stable it's a
so called anti causal filter and it will
basically amplify errors and it's not
stable as such but it is stable if you
go the
direction so in order to go the opposite
direction as a recurrence filter you
have to go from z1 over that I get this
transfer function I apply that as a
recurrence filter now the opposite
direction you see it's stable and if i
combine now these two recurrence filters
I have now an inverse cubic b-spline
filter which i can basically put in
front of the B spline interpolation and
thereby now get perfect cubic spline
interpolation as you see here so now you
see the pre-processing this with your
recurrence photo that I just developed
you now have a perfect interpolation not
an averaging in there no blurring and I
can wait a minute do this also for all
kinds of data and then of course also
for image data here for example I have
an image of the moon which I'd like to
increase which I'd like to resample or
image resize for that matter and with
all these commands like image resize
image rotate image transform they all
have intrinsically a resampling method
built in and very much depending on that
we sampling method it the quality of the
image is good or bad now this was just
the b-spline you see the blur if you
have now the pre-filter in there you see
a much more crisper result of the image
than just doing an ordinary b-spline and
this is just kind of a motivation
because we have gone to quite some
lengths to build into mathematical all
kinds of resampling routine so here you
have a list of how much how many other
whoops of 58 different resampling
methods actually they are more because
some of them go to infinite order and
not only do you have them at your
disposal when you do all kinds of image
transformations but you can call up all
kinds of properties with resampling
algorithm data you can call up the
kernel function you can call up a plot
of it
can have the effective interpolating
colonel so this was basically the Beast
band kernel of if you do the b-spline
colonel and the d blurring then
effectively you convolve or inter plate
with this kernel you can ask for the
regularity of the result so it's
continuous up to second derivative order
the size of the colonel gives you an
idea of how fast the whole thing works
you can ask for the Fourier transform of
the colonel to get an idea of what the
attenuation is indifferent resampling
techniques and so on and just to give
you another example what's worthwhile
putting some emphasis on this here we go
here I have image rotate applied several
times on an image and you see that if
you just do linear resampling the image
gets blurred quite a bit if you do cat
maram which used to be our standard one
it gets much better and if you do sample
for example quintic spline sampling or
Oh mom sampling you get even better
result but i doubt if you can see it on
this screen you will see it on another
screen so all of this underlying
machinery is there to do a image to do
signal processing in 2d now a little fun
example which I will quickly bring up
this is an image processing example that
adheres to the previous talk basically
getting a data bin in so basically what
I do here is a load of data bin of a
camera feed that was positioned here in
champaign at the headquarters and that
was basically looking at a fish tank now
loading the data will take a little bit
of times they don't want waste that I'll
just slow the data here in my notebook
and what the data looks like is as
follows
it does take a lot of time no matter
what
well I think given the amount of time
that I have left I will skip this
particular example it's not that and
just move on with other examples since I
have five minutes left only so here are
examples from our built-in image
processing capabilities that you may not
be aware of for example in which in
paint where you can just fill in for tea
areas in an image or you can synthesize
areas that are not there are basically
removing people so don't trust any image
that you see anymore because it can do
amazing things with it another example
which a quick like to do is
deconvolution deconvolution is goes as
follows basically if you blur an image
if you don't have perfect vision you
convolve your image with a colonel and
in this case I took a Gaussian kernel
and if you know your Colonel very well
then you can really decon volve to an
extremely crisp result because the data
or the information is still in that fine
grayscale values that you possibly have
originally if you have noise in the
image then already things go bad and if
you don't know the colonel exactly also
your little screwed now real live image
an image from my kids I took this image
some years ago and I love this image so
much but his little flaw the guy in my
son he's sharp but my daughter's little
blurred and I tried to fix that and he
can fix it by looking basically in her
eye because there you have a reflection
and it's a perfect image that should be
a point point like reflection and from
that reflection I can deduce the kernel
that blur the image the foreground and
from that I can then make a sharper
image so let's try this I'll just do a
little close up here I basically find
the location of the reflection I read
out the reflection here a little but by
little and then what I do here I don't
go through all the detail is basically
we derive here a good model of a kernel
basically dampening the side a little
bit taking the average of
both reflections left and right and what
I come up with is this kind of blurring
colonel so that's my blur and now once i
have that blur i can actually d convo
vit deconvolution unfortunately produces
some more noise in the image so I do a
little bit of corona Moloch blurring and
that's the result and in case you don't
believe me that this has some benefit
quickly to both before and after and
that's a typical deconvolution example
alright and okay I have one more and I'm
gonna since I know I cut into lunch here
but this is too good to skip this is an
example that you may have seen on the
internet it was really hip about one or
two years ago it was a project done by
people at the MIT image lab and what
they did is they bought they developed
an algorithm that amplifies motion in
your images in your animation so what
you have here is just the wrist and here
I have a stack of images and
unfortunately this will apparently take
a little bit of time ya just bring this
up a little bit you can I can now run
basically the movie of that wrist and
well if you say you can't see anything
it's probably true there's hardly any
motion there is some motion because
there's a pulse but you cannot see the
pulse and now I do all kinds of tricks
to see actually the pulse in that image
so let me quickly do it or explain how
it's done the idea is very simple if you
have motion in your luminosity field of
shift then in the Fourier space that is
basically multiplication with a with a
complex factor and that complex factor
that I can magnify and that's exactly
how it's done you basically convert it
into free space on different scales and
different frequency bands and then you
amplify those complex factors that you
have and then you basically convert
everything back and that gives you your
motion amplification here this is the
code
well I won't go through this and so what
I do in the code is I basically
decompose the image and a pyramid of
different scales and different
frequencies and it can also recompose
that and then I apply that mechanism and
at the end here are now pre-calculated
that because it takes about 30 seconds
to run you may see the pulse I'm not
sure if you can see it very well I can
make it may be a bit bigger the whole
thing
and here you can see that was image
processing it can even make invisible
stuff visible so that's kind of an
example now 3d processing and I think I
stop here